[Música]
esa foto el pasado 7 de abril
me encontraba justamente en ese lugar
[Música]
en la línea de largada
de uno de los maratones más importantes
del mundo como lo es el maratón de
ahorro de agua
uno de mis sueños estaba a punto de
cumplirse
habíamos practicado con mi entrenador y
con mi equipo correr en 2 horas 13 lo
cual es una marca muy ambiciosa para hoy
en día para un maratonista argentino
y para lo cual salí a correr tuve muchos
inconvenientes durante la carrera
pero logré correr 2 horas 15 48 segundos
mi marca es una marca habilitante para
el mundial de la especialidad de este
año en doha en qatar y logré salir 17
entre unos 30.000 corredores
[Música]
pero creo que eso lo puedo mejorar y así
todo creo que esto no es lo más
importante de lo que le quiero hablar
lo más importante pasa por cosas que no
se ven cosas del día a día
buenas tardes para todos mi nombre es
eulalio muñoz
nací y me crié en un pueblo llamado walk
aina que está a unos 90 km en la meseta
central de la provincia de chubut mi
infancia la hice en mi pueblo
[Música]
donde nací y bueno justamente donde me
crié nací en una familia humilde y bueno
se trata un poco de lo que les quiero
contar yo anteriormente a vivir en
gualjaina viví cinco años en el campo en
un paraje
que está a 13 km de gualjaina que se
llama costa de gualjaina
recuerdo que hacíamos 13 kilómetros de
día para ir al pueblo a comprar
alimentos o ir al hospital y 13 km de
vuelta los cuales en el día sumaba una
distancia de 26 km
y bueno recuerdo que sólo hacía
corriendo porque bueno era el más chico
de mi familia y había que caminar rápido
para que no nos agarre la noche
por lo cual se iba último corriendo y
finalmente sonando porque no me
esperaban mucho
bueno
tiempo más tarde mi familia decidió irse
a vivir a gualjaina
como les dije estuvimos cinco años en el
campo
y para aprender para emprender una nueva
vida allí en hualfín a los 89 años más o
menos comencé a jugar el fútbol
qué bueno
todo niño todo chico siempre quiere
jugar el fútbol cuando es pequeño y
bueno yo juega el fútbol también porque
me gustaba y además de eso
me gustaba viajar podría podía venir
aquel que es que en su momento para mí
era era lo máximo porque bueno yo le
digo vivían huérfana y bueno mi infancia
la pasé allí y mis vacaciones cuando
terminaba terminaron las clases las ha
pasado ya
así que a lo sumo era venir dos o tres
días a acompañar a mi papá porque venía
a cobrar su jubilación y bueno era eso
en mis vacaciones bueno como les contaba
así comencé a jugar fútbol a 289 años
aproximadamente
y bueno soñaba con jugar en primera como
todos no bueno en ese momento soñaba ser
como maradona porque me siento bien no
salían
y bueno siempre que juega el fútbol me
esforzaba y siempre trataba de
demostrarle al entrenador que tenía
muchas ganas de querer avanzar y de
poder llegar un poco más lejos
pero bueno un tiempo más tarde el club
tuvo que cerrar y bueno ese sueño de ser
como maradona de jugar en primera y de
jugar en river plate obviamente por ese
hincha de river se fumar
bueno con el tiempo
ya les cuento me gustaba entrenar me
gustaba correr y bueno un amigo me
invitó una carrera que justamente esa es
una de las carreras más importante acá
es que que es la media maratón al
paraíso y recuerdo que fue así como
estoy en la foto con un pantalón de
fútbol roto y con unas zapatillas con
las cuales juega al fútbol me fue bien
en esa carrera y fue allí donde conocí a
una entrenadora una profesora de
educación física que fue mi primer
entrenador digamos
con ella le pedí ayuda si me podía
entrenar y dijo que no había problema
así que decidimos entrenarnos y me
preparé para un provincial de cross
country que fue acá justamente en esquel
en una laguna la zeta donde salí segundo
me ganaron pero pero bueno el objetivo
mío era clasificar a un nacional
lo que más me interesaba de clasificar a
este nacional era que se hacía afuera se
hacía en una provincia que se llama
córdoba que para mí en ese momento era
lo máximo era mi viaje más largo hasta
ese momento y bueno logré salir
subcampeón nacional es mi primera
competencia en mi primera experiencia
fuera la provincia de la verdad que fue
una alegría enorme pero más allá de eso
no lo entendía todavía fue el poder
viajar y el poder estar lejos de casa
por primera vez
pero anterior a eso anterior a nacional
en el provincial
conocí a esta persona que es rodrigo
peláez mi actual entrenador a quien
solamente lo conocía porque lo escuchaba
en la radio
y sabía que era un formador de atletas
de élite de forma nacional e
internacional atleta como karina neipán
mariola los ríos martín y en cuchillos
entre otros
recuerdo que ese día un amigo hoy en día
es un amigo una persona en ese momento
se acercó y me lo presentó
al cual
cuando me acerqué me empezó a contar que
justamente ellos se iban a rotterdam con
karina neipán a buscar una marca
olímpica
a lo cual en ese momento creo que hasta
el día de hoy lo sigue pensando que yo
que estaba un poco loco porque como que
exagere mucho en la forma de decirle no
qué locura que grande porque en ese
momento para mí era lo máximo poder
competir afuera y bueno eso soñaba
internamente con cómo puede hacerlo que
lo que iba a intentar él con karina que
era buscar una marca olímpica
bueno le pedí ayuda para que si me
pudiera entrenar tiempo más tarde y me
dijo que sí sin dudarlo me dijo que
estaría muy bueno pero que lo ideal
sería que yo me vengo a vivir acá a la
ciudad es que él
recuerdo que esto fue en diciembre del
día tras día lo pensaba yo tenía 17 años
y era una decisión difícil de tomar
porque es que como se le digo era era
absolutamente nuevo para mí es que él
estaba a más de 90 kilómetros mi casa en
el cual debería vivir solo y
prácticamente no tenía a nadie y no
conocía lo suficiente como para
emprender viaje a una ciudad que es una
ciudad que no conocía
pero como la vida también se trata de
tomar decisiones
yo decidí tomar el riesgo y bueno me
vine a vivir
recuerdo que me vine a vivir acá y viví
durante tres años en una pensión
en una pensión de un amigo me levantaba
todos los días a las seis de la mañana
aves y cinco de la mañana para hacer mi
primer turno
mi primer turno de entrenamiento luego
al colegio y cuando salía del colegio
pasaba a lo que es el café centro de
acción familiar
el cual pasa a trabajar por unas horas
porque me daban una beca de mil pesos
con lo cual si yo vivía y por suerte
también podría comer ahí el mediodía
una beca de mil pesos con lo cual 400
pesos estaban destinados a pagar la
pensión y con los 600 pesos que me
sobraban comidas
así pasaron unos tres años
aproximadamente sin lujos sin ropa nueva
sin zapatillas pero siempre con
con la mente puesta en mis sueños con
las cosas que se anhelaba y con la con
con los sueños que me había propuesto
cuando salía igual fina
pero también en ese momento después de
tres meses después de que él
por primera vez mi papá que vivía en
gualjaina porque les digo que me vine a
vivir solo
tres meses después
el cae en cama por primera vez se
enfermó y tuvo que ser internado
dos días antes de mi cumpleaños mi papá
muere y este fue uno de los momentos más
tristes de mi vida y de lo más duro
recuerdo que
en un momento llegué a pensar que yo era
el culpable de que esto a mi papá le
sucediera porque yo cuando vivía en
gualjaina siempre estaba con él y
trataba de ayudarlo siempre en todo lo
que podía
pero también gracias a los amigos
a todos entendí también que esto es
parte de la vida
esto es parte de la vida y que bueno
esto tiene que pasar por eso es que
ahora cada vez que llego a meta en una
carrera siempre miro al cielo y se lo
dedico él
leí con mi carrera en cuba
fue una experiencia difícil la que me
tocó pasar porque bueno se le descuente
un poco
pero siempre tenían claro por lo cual yo
había venido a vivir aquel que era para
cumplir mis sueños mis metas
muchas veces cuando uno vive en un
pueblo lo único que necesita son
oportunidades
oportunidades para que se te brindan
para salir a buscar tus sueños porque no
muchas veces que hay que quedarse con
que no tengo la oportunidad y no lo
puedo hacer
creo que esto va más allá porque no
siempre las cosas van a estar ahí y hay
que salir a buscarlas
siempre intentarlo
y siempre tratar de ir en busca de
nuestros sueños muchas veces vamos a
caer pero tenemos que levantarnos y
seguir existiendo perseverar y seguir
insistiendo seguir existiendo hasta que
las cosas
una vez en facebook en una de mis redes
sociales escribí que me gustaría correr
para algunas de las marcas adidas nike
biobalas una marcas xy bueno puede
representar esta marca también soñaba
con
con tener algunos récords soñaba con
correr para la selección argentina ser
pollo argentino
soñaba con correr un sudamericano
pero siempre tenía en mente que para
estas cosas debería tener una gran
actitud mi entrenador siempre me lo dijo
que para lograr grandes cosas
tenemos que tener grandes actitudes
ser perseverante en lo que queremos
hacer
y nunca dejar de intentarlo pero siempre
siempre pensando que somos iguales a
todos nunca creciendo nos mejor que
nadie ni nada de eso
a veces los sueños son tan relativos o
tan diferentes que por ahí alguna cosa
tan pequeña o algún sueño tan ambicioso
se ven tan lejanos y uno deja de
intentarlo pero pero ahí está la clave
el no dejar de intentarlo
el insistir en insistir hasta
hasta lograr nuestras metas
hoy solo tengo 23 años
corro para una de las mejores marcas
como los nike pertenezco al team
herbalife
de pasar a cobrar una beca de mil pesos
hoy tengo un trabajo un trabajo fijo que
me permite entrenar tranquilo y
solamente pienso en entrenar
represente a la selección argentina
fui varias veces campeón nacional y
podio sudamericano
y como ya les conté al principio lo haré
una marca habilitante para
para el mundial de doha este año en
qatar
a lo que voy con esto ya lo que quiero
para ir cerrando contarles y decirles es
que todos podemos
siendo un pueblo chico siendo una ciudad
grande todos podemos solamente pasa en
insistir en creer ir en busca de
nuestros sueños
y a veces se necesita eso que algunos
llaman suerte
los que para algunos se llama suerte
para mí se llaman para mí son mis
creencias porque son mis creencias las
que me ayudaron a levantarme momentos
difíciles
porque son mis creencias las cuales me
permiten estar acá hoy frente a usted
hablándoles
y porque son mis creencias las cuales me
permiten vivir
y son mis creencias con las cuales
siempre seguiré y nunca abandonaré
muchísimas veces
[Aplausos]